Aurora's are spectacular these dancing
lights visit the polar skies when
charged particles strike the Earth's of
her atmosphere causing the atoms and
molecules there to glow in a variety of
colors now there's a new dancer into a
thin purple Ark named Steve the
phenomenon was first spotted by citizen
scientists observing the aurora in
addition to its unusual color steve also
stood out based on its location
it appeared closer to the equator than
other Aurora's which are typically
spotted at latitudes between 65 and 80
degrees the regions of the atmosphere
where these light shows normally occur
form a large oval over each magnetic
pole of the earth during times of
increased solar activity these ovals
broadened moving toward the equator this
feature dubs Steve by citizen
photographers who were surprised but it
just kept showing up in the skies over
southern Canada was a narrow purple line
in the night sky citizen photographers
have captured hundreds of images of
Steve over the last few years usually
during times of increased auroral
activity in July 2016 the European Space
Agency's swarm a satellite flew over
Steve revealing that a previously known
phenomenon called sub or aural ion drift
or sa ID may explain its unusual
properties sa IDs are narrow regions of
charged particles moving rapidly to the
west sometimes at speeds exceeding 5
kilometers per second researchers
believe that Steve is simply an optical
manifestation of an SI ID phenomenon
that's been measured before but never
seen thanks to satellite data and
observations from citizen scientists
researchers now have a better
understanding of this atmospheric
feature and a nod to the original
informal name scientists have suggested
that it be called a strong thermal
emission velocity enhancement otherwise
known as
Steve the discovery of Steve helps
highlight the importance of citizen
science and the many ways in which
professional scientists enthusiastic
amateurs work together
[Music]
you
you